alain houpert ciric isaac sibille
bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans la matinale de rtl france c'est
matin pour échanger pour débattre sur
l'actualité notamment sur cette rentrée
des classes aujourd'hui pour les membres
du gouvernement avec la question du coc
vie de 19 et la vaccination en tête des
préoccupations d'exécutif
particulièrement la rentrée scolaire
alors votre avis le protocole annoncé en
début de semaine par le ministre de
l'éducation est ce que selon vous il est
suffisamment adapté on va commencer avec
vous et là on perd
bon j'ai trébuché et une mention
spéciale à jean-michel bancaire qui
institutionnalise la discrimination dans
les bancs de l'école les non vaccinés
mais non malades sont envoyés chez eux
les vaccinés qui peuvent parfaitement
être porteurs ont le droit de venir en
classe et contaminent leurs camarades on
est dans l'absurdité totale le ministre
jean louis chef dans le caire a quand
même amputé son son budget de 2021 de
600 millions d'euros ce qui est énorme
alors qu'eux ils se livrent des choses
très important dans les hémicycles que
ce soit au sénat ou à l'assemblée
nationale chers collègues ou au conseil
de paris au conseil de paris une
conseillère du viiie arrondissement à un
mille le point sur les purificateurs
d'air
il ya deux cent cinquante mille classes
en france un taux refi 14 heures ça vaut
500 500 euros il suffit de 25 millions
d'euros pour purifier les classes alors
que en tout l'été on a désinfecté des
classes pendant deux mois qu'ils n'ont
pas vu d'élèves donc on est dans dans le
mépris et la précarisation des
enseignements mais enseignants ont
priviligié les privilégiés on surveille
et en punissant
on allait il fut terminée puisque isaac
sibille vous répondrai
j'ai l'impression qu'elle sentiment que
cette rentrée scolaire sera celle de la
rentrée de la campagne présidentielle où
on verra les slogans d'une prison la
république un petit père des peuples qui
a su protéger nos concitoyens
relancer l'économie et remettre la
france en marche plutôt remettre la
france au pas alors une rentrée scolaire
jugé comme absurdes discrimination sur
les bancs d'école vient de nous dire
alain houpert qu'est ce que vous en
pensez si rivier isaac sibille
bonjour à vous et bonjour à vos
téléspectateurs d'abord d'abord j'ai une
pensée moi je suis donc en service
cription jeu comment j'ai commencé à
travailler depuis lundi en allant voir
l'ensemble des directeurs des équipes
pédagogiques d'abord j'ai une pensée
pour les professeurs et les équipes
pédagogiques qui vont avoir à mettre en
place ces mesures sanitaires ça c'est la
première chose c'est l'axé pas simple
c'est vrai que moi je suis très fier je
suis très fier que notre pays ait été
celui qui est permis que les enfants
sont scolarisés durant la crise
sanitaire ils permettent que nos enfants
puissent à peut-être encore scolarisés
donc s'agir on est le seul pays dans le
monde où ils ont fort on continue être
scolarisés et on sait l'importance que
ça au niveau social au niveau
pédagogique au niveau psychologique donc
moi je suis un peu surpris de la part de
cette opposition c'est normal c'est
normal la majorité gouverne le
gouvernement prend des mesures
l'opposition moi je croyais que les
républicains est un parti de
gouvernement
les propos que j'entends la cc66 des
yaka faut qu on a on a on en a
l'impression de d'écouter ce qu'on
entend vis-à-vis pas sanitaires je ne
sais pas si sinon jusqu'à maintenant on
avait une opposition qui pouvaient être
crédibles qui pointe une alternative
maintenant effectivement je n'arrive pas
à comprendre ses propos qu'ils soient
extrêmes moi j'ai dit trois choses
premièrement je salue visites
pédagogiques c'est vrai que ça sera pas
simple s'il vrai que vis-à-vis des
enfants des villes et par an il ya
certaines craintes on va faire en sorte
de prendre toutes les mesures pour que
les choses se passent bien et que pure
pour que les enfants puissent être
scolarisés continuer leurs études et si
la caractéristique de la france durant
cette crise alain houpert peut-être une
réponse sur vos propos qui sont jugée
extrême par parle le modèle la majorité
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous répondez
mon collègue a parlé de l'opposition
comme s'ils
s'opposent et
tettey ne pas accepter le débat
l'opposition française demandent un
débat vous à me poser beaucoup de
questions premier ministre beaucoup de
questions président de la république
aucune réponse on est dans une session
verticale de la crise alors que on est
dans une gestion on devrait dans une
gestion
horizontal et je ne dis pas il ya qu'à
faut qu'on il faut écouter on a parlé
beaucoup de ce vaccin de boucliers lac
sinal mais il faudra pour cette rentrée
scolaire inventer un nouveau vaccin
celui du vaccin contre la grève et où
sont les syndicats où sont les syndicats
la seule opposition
en france ce sont les républicains ils
sont à l'écouté du peuple vous avez
parlé du pasteur il ya eu beaucoup de
manifestations
j'ai vu dans les médias je suis allé à
la dernière manifestation c'est pas mon
habitude j'ai vu énormément de monde je
constate qu'il ya une grande différence
entre la comptabilisation des
manifestants par le gouvernement et si
ce qu'est ce qui se passe au sein du
peuple vous avez dit cher confrère il ne
fallait pas diviser l'europe mais les
français qui étaient à leurs fenêtres
ont vu des centaines de milliers de
français
défilent et jean pierre raffarin disait
que c'est pas très virulent mais
aussi le peuple qui vous gouvernent et
il faut entendre le ridiculisant
cyrille isaac sibille peut être une
réponse sur ses interrogations et ses
vrais ans qu'on entend alors du côté de
l'opposition mais pas seulement lente
aussi dans la rue des français
s'interrogent notamment sur sur le
chiffre de 2 de ces manifestations on a
vu des gens venir en nombre dans les
rues quel est votre regard sur sur cette
mobilisation
d'abord très présente très écouté je
rappellerai à mon collègue que le
gouvernement a consulté l'ensemble des
présidents de groupe que ce soit au
niveau du sénat que ce sont des vrais
sommet national et 4 guillemets en privé
ses responsables de groupes sont tous ok
pour la vaccination et pour le pass à
lithaire en tout cas c'est ce qu'ils ont
dit au premier ministre et c'est pour ça
que c'est plus intéressant que lorsqu'on
est en responsabilité on est ok puis
lorsqu'il équipements on est valable
patrie on y compte moi je suis je suis
un peu surpris monsieur comme j ai que
ce soit il nous il ya les défis qu'on ne
passe à l'unité avec monsieur di filippo
ça m'inquiète par rapport à démocratie
ça m'inquiète par rapport à la
démocratie
ça c'est la ccid une première chose moi
moi les chiffres j'entends bien des
chiffres moi j'ai un chiffre et c'est
celui qui m'intéresse c'est les plus de
40 millions de français qui sont allés
la chine et échoue à cuba en octobre
lors de doses dans une dans un pays qui
aient quelques minutes quelques dizaines
de billets personnes qui soient pas
d'accord c'est normal et c'est même sens
mais comparant les chiffres + 50
millions plus de 40 millions de français
qui ont leurs deux doses et qui sont
protégés par rapport à quelques dizaines
de milles qui manifestent c'est normal
qu'ils manifestent moi j'ai moi j'ai pu
comprendre c'était plus tous les
extrêmes qui manifestaient maintenant je
j'entends que maintenant même les bébés
qu'elles vont manifester avec monsieur
di filippo quelque part et c'est ça qui
est intéressant il y ait des gens et je
pense qu'il y ait une majorité chaînon
ses responsabilités on paye la rentrée
scolaire monsieur bancaire qui prend les
mesures pour faire en sorte que les plie
de 0,60 voir sur scolarisés et puis
après et il y a un oeil à 15 millions de
français qui sont la chine et puis
d'autres côté fille qui montre il ya des
gens qui manifestent ils sont pas
d'accord qui seront rejoints par les
républicains j'en suis un p'tit belgique
alors concernant le pass sanitaires y en
a un qui est sorti de son silence hier
qui s'est exprimé à ce sujet c'est le
patron du medef geoffroy roux de bézieux
et pour lui ce pass sanitaires il doit
durer le moins longtemps possible alors
est-ce que quoi qu'il arrive la fin du
pass sanitaire elle doit être actée au
15 novembre
est ce que c'est une priorité seul de ce
doit être une priorité pour le
gouvernement selon oil a ouvert
parce que nos mii est sous perfusion bah
sanitaire actuellement elle obère
l'économie de ceux qui souffrent les ce
sont les restaurateurs la restauration
française l'hôtellerie nous le tri des
thèmes et par terre et ceux qui peuvent
se relever actuellement les
restaurateurs et hôteliers ils peuvent
se relever sous conditions celui de se
substituer au travail de l'état c'est à
dire contrôler les cuillères sous peine
d'amendé de faillite monsieur mon cher
collègue monsieur sybille nous avait dit
que j'ai manifesté avec les extrêmes je
n'ai rien à voir avec monsieur
l'ancien rassemblement national je n'ai
rien à voir avec ça et je suis très
heureux de faire un parti qui a le mot
républicain dedans tout à l'heure
[Musique]
le présentateur a fait un lapsus en
disant que vous étiez en député de
modèle je dirais que vous êtes un député
du modèle modèle proche proche du
gouvernement
ce qui nous différencie c'est la vue des
chiffres sortons de cette querelle des
chiffres divisés de français parce que
les chiffres on les a vu le nombre de
mensonges
depuis le début de ce set et astres les
masques l'utilité la non d'utilité sur
les peuples je me méfie complètement de
vichy que je vois en tant qu'élu terrain
c'était le mécontentement qui gagne et
le président de la république est en
train de perdre son capital de sympathie
je sais qu'il ya un sondage qui vient de
sortir ou le président macron est à 41%
d'opinions
sagorin je demande et je me pose la
question où sont ses 41 % est ce qu'ils
sont dans les villes qui sont
complètement
gentrifié bogota lisez ou dans la
campagne ou simplement dans les
quartiers populaires mais je suis allé à
une seule manifestation
eh bien j'ai lu des gens comme vous je
cible les gens comme moi des gens qui
sont modérés qui sont posées qu'ils se
posent des questions et arrêter de
confondre les gens qui sont contre le
pas salutaire et les gens qui sont
contre la vaccination
les gens qui sont là la distinction on
va laisser la parole à monsieur civile
ou fait effectivement cette distinction
entre les les anti vaccins et les
anti-pacs sanitaire
pas sanitaire moi je pense que ces tirs
a été favorable à l'économie
moi je préfère le pass annie terre au
profil mans mon cher collègue est ce que
vous préférez vivement que ont de
nouveau enferme les restaurants concerne
les hôtels confirmé comme gers non le
passé ni terre ça permet l'ouverture
et c'est pour ça que je suis d'accord
avec monsieur europe et dieu par rapport
au medef c'est le principe qu'il faut
c'est que l'économie reprenne l'économie
reprendra et reprend et on le voit grâce
au pass sanitaire le passé militaire
doit évite le confinement
permet la reprise à me taire et
permettra bientôt effectivement d'avoir
de nouveaux j'espère une vie normale
elle sera jamais tout à fait normal mais
elle sera normal pas le plus rapidement
possible pour que de nouveaux
équipements le qe2 mais reprennent sur
le principe de la durée j'y suis
d'accord plus pas sanitaires sur un bref
mieux ça sera comme comme vous le savez
effectivement le mouvement démocrate
avait demandé fille qu'il manque ce ne
soit pas le leu leu leu des lesparrains
par la crise et des retours par le 1er
octobre
on a été écouté maintenant le pass
unitaire il est prévu jusqu'au 15
novembre
et bien évidemment l'assemblée nationale
et vous chers que les glossines a de
nouveau ramenés on si avant le 15
novembre savoir sur le maintien ou si on
le supprime et donc c'est toute
l'intelligence des choses je trouve de
ces mesures c'est évidemment qu'elles
soient efficaces qu elle permet des
économies et qu'elles sont provisoires
il faut qu'ils soient provisoires et je
me battrai pour que ce taux provisoire
je me batte fait pour que le se passa ni
terre ne s'installe pas de manière
durable dans notre pays en tout cas
c'est ce que fait le crâne à
l'association mais il nous reste
quelques minutes au coeur des attentions
ces dernières heures ces dernières jours
c'est la ville de marseille avec tout
cet os tous ces règlements de compte la
situer la situation sécuritaire le chef
de l'état doit s'y rendre la semaine
prochaine le jour de la rentrée
d'ailleurs pour annoncer un grand plan
pour la ville pour les écoles notamment
est ce que vous comprenez que ce soit le
chef de l'état qui prennent les choses
en main à marseille alain houpert
que je sèche est enfoncé on parle du
déplacement du président de la
république tape s'ils se rendaient en
terre inconnue pour prendre en compte
des spécificités
ils sont tout à fait historique
mémorielle locales à marseille oui mais
agir avec des pincettes
non
j'ai l'impression que est en train de
mettre le feu au pays l'état de droit
doit être le même partout seuls les
moyens pour y parvenir sont différents
et il paraît que donc puisque vous
l'avez dit que le président va annoncer
une grande politique de la ville mais
moi j'aurais aimé rêver que le président
il ya trois ans ne balaye pas d'un
revers de main le plan de jean louis
borloo qui était un plan extrêmement
ambitieux
voilà donc marseille est une partie de
la france mars le prénom de la
république est en train de rentrer en
campagne électorale et sa femme très
important d'écouter ce qu'il va dire
parce que la france les français dans
l'écouté qui sont dans des régions de
non droit nous dans les régions de droit
lorsque la france elle est divisée et
jean louis borloo c'est quelqu'un qui
connaît bien la politique de la ville et
moi je préconise représente d'appui la
république d'écouter ce grand homme
d'état qui s'appelle jean louis borloo
pour écouter ses conseils sir isaac
sibille emmanuel macron il va à
marseille pour faire de la communication
à huit mois des présidentielles selon
vous non je pense que le contrat public
issue publiée jeudi des usines
françaises et on voit bien qu'à
marseille il ya un problème dispose on
voit bien la violence qui est en train
de renier et à graz installés dans ces
deux lieux moi je trouve ça intéressant
celui des bas qu'on a on va voir sur le
cannabis il ya des gens qui souhaitent
qu'ils sont pour la légalisation du
cannabis
des gens qui sont contre bayonne des
gens qui veulent comme en discute
d'ailleurs regardez je suis favorable je
suis favorable au fait qu'on en discute
regardez à me le dire en public à la
marseille parce qu'il parce qu'il ya des
violences qui s'installe parce qu'il ya
un problème avec la drogue si le prêt à
vendre ce problème avec la drogue est
vieux de notre pays et je pense qu'il
est bien qu'il est saint connan pas
voyez à ce propos d'ailleurs de cette
problématique qui est une grosse
pratiques de nos villes actuellement
vous voyez à ce propos la sécurité à ce
propos ce que propose sébastien barles
l'adjoint au maire de marseille sur la
question du trafic de drogue
encore un drame lié au trafic à
marseille la prohibition du cannabis est
une impasse la légalisation permettrait
de faire baisser le trafic est
d'empêcher la lutte armée entre les
trafiquants et mener une politique de
santé publique de prévention à la ouvert
vous rejoignez cette position de
sébastien barles pas du tout je tends le
montant investi médecin il paraît
m'exprimer en tant que médecin puisque
je suis parlementaire mais le radiologue
j'ai fait beaucoup de neuroradiologie
j'ai vu les dégâts de la pète sur le sur
les cerveaux pénil ans que l'afflux est
alors lantern hal désociabilisés je suis
d'accord avec mon collègue il faut un
débat et elle devient coûteux sur le
plan médical et jeu là je serais
d'accord avec notre ministre de
l'intérieur qui dit qui a dit que les
délinquants ne vont pas du jour au
lendemain ouvrir des petites échoppes et
payer la tva c'est un problème
économique et l'économie souterraine est
en train de prendre le pas sur les
quartiers et sur les villes et il ya un
événement important dans le monde
c'est la chute de la vie ganis temps et
la prise de kaboul par les talibans et
80% de l'héroïne son procès est produite
en afghanistan et je redoute qu'il y à
un déferlement de cocaïne et d'héroïne
sur l'occident il n'y a une frontière
très poreuse entre les drogues douces
parce qu'il n'ya pas de bouche et les
drogues dures quand quelqu'un tombe dans
la drogue douce et dans la dépression
est actuellement cette époque avec ce qu
vide avec cette maladie horrible
entraîne les gens dans la dépression et
en particulier les jeunes qui vont aller
vers justement la fumette je suis contre
la légalisation du cannabis
on sait quand on paie de st je vois les
dégâts que ça
au vert sur le cerveau je pense pas que
quand on
fume régulièrement du cannabis on puisse
un jour faire polytechnique
puisqu'on le faire des enfants c'était
espérer le meilleur pour eux et je pense
qu'il faut éduquer nos enfants pour
qu'ils ne tombent pas vers l'addiction
qu'elle soit celle du tabac ou de la
fumette pour un jour où tout bascule
pour tomber dans des drogues plus dures
c'est un discours populaire est un
discours populiste de dire qu'il faut
légaliser le cannabis série les accies
ville vous aurez le mot de la fin il
nous reste assez peu de temps est ce
qu'on vous met d'accord sur cette
question pour conclure de la
légalisation du cannabis c'est pas le
problème n'est pas envisageable
aujourd'hui pour nous il ya deux sujets
ya plein de sanitaires et je rejoins mon
beau-frère et collectifs qui m'ont
personne ne peut affirmer
que le quai les drogues sont bons pour
la santé donc pia moi je peux rejoindre
après il ya le côté victime l'économique
l'économie parallèle je suis en
désaccord point je suis de départ donc
je sais pas s'il ya débat il faut pas
d'emblée affirmé les choses mais je
m'interroge pour savoir beaucoup sur le
côté économique si éric images procès
représente 4 à 5 milliards cette
économie souterraine sur les gars vie
qu'on supprime ces quatre à cinq
milliards viviane famille certains
quartiers certaines banlieues qui vivent
de ça je crains malheureusement que les
violences compose à marseille ce
transfert sur d'autres trafics et je ne
crois pas que la liège l égalisation
supprimera les violences ces taux plein
d'argent ici un peu d'argent il ya
toujours des gens dans les quartiers qui
se battront pour cet argent pourrait
être géré cet argent ça soit à travers
la drogue ou à travers d'autres trafics
à grand merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france merci à vous ou cyrille isaac
sibille député modem de la 12e
circonscription du rhône merci à vous à
la houppe heures sénateurs les
républicains et côte d'or